Alice jaqobis poetry on em prevents
certain access but basically my question
is on we started weed yes right yes
[Music]
there is a company called head meadow a
bat by Y Combinator either copy of the
tuber for the week everybody's calling
do everything big uber of everything I'm
The Improv humans [ __ ] but that
beautiful physically fighting is encoded
in lot of confidence with the doctor
yep is your car all that okay but I'll
it doesn't work great right now the
other dish before you started talking
about steam yes okay the rise of the
rest and everyone has an opportunity
hey so what about people who are like
selling or the one who okay absolutely
don't do it as they're entrepreneurs of
purest forms
well seriously but like if somebody was
born into well right this is a home
value at school yeah okay they need to
get $150,000 a year don't get a twisted
man
stop your hate real quick most people
that get monies in Silicon Valley don't
come from [ __ ] Silicon Valley so stop
it right there or keep going but I'm not
letting you just cliche it because
that's [ __ ] she's not true good no
how does okay like what is the movie
[ __ ] Denver [ __ ] [ __ ] simple
because that's the current law why do I
hate Texas with all my heart because I
yeah I'll tell you exactly right here
face
I hate Texas I listen I hate to sin more
than you [ __ ] hate the system right
now because I built the wine business
where I shipped wine and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] aside state two expects money
the politicians have blocked only one
store from shipping the Texas me because
I was at the top of the heap I was doing
four million in sales here saving all
Texas people money because I was
creating competition and the wholesalers
three of them paid more [ __ ] [ __ ]
at Houston politicians to block me from
shipping here and one day I got a letter
and said you can't ship here anymore
so what am I supposed to do I can open a
store in [ __ ] Texas and throw down or
I can adjust that's what you have to do
nobody gives a [ __ ] about your feelings
bro some number for real like click and
the reason I'm coming at you like this
without pulse for you you're a kid like
don't cry about here's the biggest
problem
[ __ ] entrepreneurs cry about the way
they want it to be instead of reacting
to the way it actually is so you need to
eliminate rich kids because I was born
with dick I live in a studio apartment
with eight family members on the sides
of the stage and split toilet paper ok
so there's no excuse that some most
people that are born with wealth bro
they lose because they're soft so if
you're so angry put it to good energy
and go move to Denver or
enjoying 19 to 22 chill then move to
dinner or wait for the laws to change
you can't cry about how it is that's
just never ever ever ever the right move
I would argue that there was not enough
clapping for that part right there and
and that's a collection I'm not the
collective energy of this room is
[ __ ] let's step it off [ __ ] that was
something real [ __ ] that was the real
kids need and oh my god [ __ ] that was
[ __ ] real
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]